today Croatia beat England in these
semi-finals of the World Cup racing line
who's nice it's really nice it's the
first time in a while I've heard people
say way to go Croatia and now if it's
something you don't hear all the time
you know
good going Croat what is it they're
called they're called crow ads which is
also that donut that was really popular
in New York I believe I'm confused
that was a cronut ok sorry how did they
do in the World Cup Pro naxi I did not
do what Hershey have failed poor crow
Nasia why can't they catch a break I was
thinking about been a very stressful
week so far first 12 tie soccer players
were trapped in a cave with rising water
you know and now 6 world leaders were
trapped in a summit with President Trump
[Applause]
just picturing him in the cave at the
water come out that President Trump's
new communications director has changed
the White House lighting so Trump looks
younger yeah even more impressive the
new lighting makes Melania look happy
[Applause]
sarah palin did hear about this sarah
palin is complaining that she was
tricked and humiliated by comedian Sacha
Baron Cohen yes
yep partly ten years ago he tricked
Palin into thinking she was actually
qualified to be vice president what else
oh it is interesting a company has come
out with a this is real a $5,000 robot
that applauds for you indefinitely
yeah in a related story I'll be working
from home I love that just me stepping
out of the shower in the morning and
just getting a huge blood doesn't know
now I don't know what you're picturing
but it's not good it's really not the
founder of Papa John's Pizza use the
n-word during a conference call about
how to avoid bad publicity of course for
Papa John's the n-word is nutrition
you